[Musique]
mais je suis juste ici en train de survivre alors
ce que je fais en ce moment, je n'aurai même pas d'
importance bébé bébé hey cash combien de
temps je suis parti pour mon argent
Dieu a fait cette terre pour nous tous gourmands
des gens comme toi veulent le monopoliser pour
toi et ta famille et moi et ma
famille ouais
Cassius je suis ton oncle j'ai juste vraiment
besoin d'un travail ou faire aussi c'est du
télémarketing s'en tenir au script
bonjour mr.  Davison Cassius vert ici
désolé - mais laissez-moi vous dire - vous
voulez gagner de l'argent ici en utilisant vos
garçons blancs mes garçons blancs vous parlez toujours
de la femme de Will Smith comme ce jeune
homme
hé mr.  Kramer, c'est Langston d'un
point de vue royal, comme toujours, nous vous le dirons
tout de suite, vous vous débrouillez
si bien avec la voix
[Musique]
vous montez à l'étage, ils ont même
leur propre ascenseur, bienvenue à l'appelant
J'espère que vous l'avez fait  ne pas se masturber aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de vous pointu et prêt à partir j'ai
chargé ma couleur de puissance aujourd'hui donc ils
ne me vendent pas mais nous savons certainement
qu'il n'y a aucune somme d'argent qui me fait
faire ça voici le salaire de départ c'est
moralement émacié je ne peux pas  rouler avec toi
je fais quelque chose pour lequel je suis vraiment bon -
ils te font une proposition je vois que
tu voudrais dire non mais je ne ferais pas
ça avant que tu vois ce que je t'offre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous